let me explain after the holidays okay
you know me andy i love looking through
the bargain bin you see the coffee table
books that nobody else bought right the
ones that were real duds that went
nowhere right okay we've collected the
biggest stinkers from the holidays these
ones just didn't sell you might see why
when we start to show them and we
thought we'd share them with you right
now and i think you're gonna enjoy that
for example here's one didn't sell at
all it's called
butterflies that sold out these are
butterflies oh dude dude why and look at
this look at this one right here a
beautiful monarch but no
that's actually kind of pretty it
actually is pretty and then down here we
got this guy that's just
why
here's one
shopping mall santa's shopping mall
santa's without the beards or
santa outfits this is them
back in civilian life
it's just somehow not the same
yeah and there's this guy down here
hey looks familiar hey i know that guy
all right self-parking cars uh are a big
story at this year's consumer
electronics show cars that can just park
themselves look at this one
self-parking cars that are [ __ ] oh
my god look at that thing
that is not right yeah you don't take up
two spots and then look at that
on top of the porsche
i don't know why this one did i love
this book
stoned
horses these are horses
[Applause]
it's 4 20 in the barn yeah look at that
[Applause]
[Music]
look at this one this is very
interesting this book
pervs pointing at non-sexual holes thus
making them kind of sexual
look at that that's just a regular hole
ah
[Music]
actually can i have that one yeah
i don't know why this is so i love this
coffee table book people who don't know
why the f you're asking if they caught
last night's downton abbey
[Applause]
look at this one right here smug guys
who have no idea they're about to be
crushed by boulders
these guys are showing a lot of tune
right there oh boy
but they're about to die
crushed by a boulder look at this dick
right here
i'm sorry when we give me a new body in
a photo shoot yeah yeah why can't it be
a little better than the one i had
well look at that that's the worst body
it definitely is it's awful i hate it